so once we've made the plant how do we
get out
i'm hoping you have something more
elegant in mind than shooting me in the
head
a kick what's a kick this
would be a kick
after fantasy franchises like lord of
the rings and harry potter convince
audiences to realize that well
being a geek is fun people emerged in
the early 2010s thinking
what next why science fiction of course
the genre
hit the decade with full force starting
with a number of inescapable series from
years past
we're talking the return of star wars
mad max
blade runner and even planet of the apes
oh
no oh no
no
[Music]
okay of course it wasn't all just
nostalgia plays but also
thought-provoking original material like
ex machina arrival
looper inception and interstellar and
although sci-fi is often set in the
future
its stories actually help inform and
decipher how we live today
through technology and allegory like in
her snow piercer or the lobster for
example
otherwise if sci-fi to you means giant
robots and monsters there was godzilla
kong skull island ready player one and
pacific rim
whatever the style or budget we took
every sci-fi movie from the last decade
and then used a ranking formula that
factors in how many critic reviews a
movie has
and how long ago the movie came out oh
what a day
what a lovely day so now it is time for
us to launch into the stars with the
best sci-fi movies of the 2010s
[Music]
number 10 snow piercer a
post-apocalyptic ice age forces
humanity's last survivors aboard a
globe-spanning super train
one man will risk everything to lead a
revolt for control of the engine
and the future of the world starring
chris evans song kang ho
tilda swinton and directed by bong
joon-ho critics say
snow piercer offers an audaciously
ambitious action spectacular for film
goers numb to effects driven
blockbusters
18 years ago today
you people who have suckled the generous
titty of wilfred
ever since shelter
and now in front of our
hallowed water supply section
nonetheless
you repair his kindness with
violent organisms
precisely 74 of you shall die
my friend you suffer from the misplaced
optimism of the doomed
number nine the martian when astronauts
blast off from the planet mars they
leave behind mark watney
presumed dead after a fierce storm with
only a meager amount of supplies
the stranded visitor must utilize his
wits and spirit to find a way to survive
on the hostile planet
meanwhile back on earth members of nasa
and a team of international scientists
worked tirelessly to bring him home
while his crewmates hatched their own
plan for a daring rescue mission
starring matt damon jessica chastain
kristen wiig
and directed by ridley scott critics say
smart thrilling
and surprisingly funny the martian
offers a faithful adaptation of the
best-selling book that brings out the
best in leading man matt damon and
director ridley scott
if we could talk democracy we would tell
him to stay put and to trust that we are
doing everything in our power
to bring him home alive don't say bring
him home alive vincent i don't want
these interviews
uneasy annie no more vincent on tv copy
that
76 kilometers am i reading that right
yes sir
mark drove two hours straight away from
the hab did a short eva and then drove
for another two he didn't load up the
oxygenator or the water reclaimer
every 41 hours there's a 17-minute gap i
want that gap down to four minutes
let's make it happen bruce what's the
earliest we can get a pre-supply there
it'll take nine months three months
three times you're going to say it's
impossible and then you're going to do
the math in your head and say something
like the overtime alone will be a
nightmare your overtime alone will be a
nightmare
get started i'll find you the money
we'll do our best
mark dies if you don't number eight
blade runner 2049
officer k a new blade runner for the los
angeles police department
unearths a long buried secret that has
the potential to plunge what's left of
society
into chaos his discovery leads him on a
quest to find rick deckard
a former blade runner who's been missing
for 30 years starring ryan gosling
harrison ford anna de armas and directed
by denny velanu
critics say visually stunning and
narratively satisfying blade runner 2049
deepens and expands its predecessor
story while standing as
an impressive filmmaking achievement in
its own right what happened to the kid
who put it in the orphanage was it you
was long gone by then
you didn't even meet your own kid
why because that was the plan
i showed them how to scramble the
records cover their tracks
everyone had a part mine was to leave
then the black out came paved over
everything couldn't have found the child
if i tried
did you want to not really
why not because we were being hunted
i didn't want our child found taken
apart
dissected
sometimes to love someone
you gotta be a stranger
number seven sorry to bother you in an
alternate reality of present-day oakland
california telemarketer cassius green
finds himself in a macabre universe
after he discovers a magical key that
leads to material glory
as green's career begins to take off his
friends and co-workers organize a
protest against corporate oppression
cassius soon falls under the spell of
steve lift a cocaine snorting ceo who
offers him a salary beyond his wildest
dreams
starring lakeith stanfield tessa
thompson jermaine fowler and directed by
boots riley
critics say fearlessly ambitious
scathingly funny
and thoroughly original sorry to bother
you loudly heralds the arrival of a
fresh filmmaking talent in writer
director boots riley
hey youngblood let me give you two use
your white boys
man i got no white voice oh come on you
know what i mean
you have a white voice in there you can
use it
it's like being pulled over by the
police oh
no i just use my regular voice when that
happens i just say
back the [ __ ] up off the car and don't
nobody get hurt man i'm just trying to
give you some cane
you want to make some money here then
read the script with the white boys
when people say i talk with a white
voice anyway so why aren't they helping
me out
well you don't talk white enough i'm not
talking about will smith's wife i'm
talking about the real deal
thank this youngblood hey mr kramer this
is langston from regal view
i didn't catch you at the wrong time did
i
number six war for the planet of the
apes
caesar and his apes are forced into a
deadly conflict with an army of humans
led by a ruthless colonel
after the apes suffer unimaginable
losses caesar wrestles with his darker
instincts and begins his own mythic
quest to avenge his kind
as the journey finally brings them face
to face caesar and the colonel are
pitted against each other in an epic
battle that will determine the fate of
both of their species and the future of
the planet
starring andy serkis woody harrelson and
directed by matt reeves
critics say war for the planet of the
apes combines breathtaking special
effects
and a powerful poignant narrative to
conclude this rebooted trilogy on a
powerful and truly blockbuster note
have you finally come to save your apes
okay for me
oh my god look at your eyes
almost human how did you know i was here
i was told you were coming
that more soldiers
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
who told you that
okay
[Music]
let's go
number five gravity dr ryan stone is a
medical engineer on her first shuttle
mission
her commander is veteran astronaut matt
kowalski helming his last flight before
retirement
then during a routine spacewalk by the
pair disaster strikes
the shuttle is destroyed leaving ryan
and matt stranded in deep space with no
link to earth and no hope of rescue
as fear turns to panic they realize that
the only way home may be to venture
further into space
starring sandra bullock george clooney
ed harris and directed by alfonso cuaron
critics say alfonso cuadron's gravity is
an eerie tense sci-fi thriller that's
masterfully directed and visually
stunning
ah
houston in the blind to confirm mission
specialist
dr stone and mission commander matthew
kowalski are the sole survivors of the
sds
157
i apologize for not complying i should
have stopped working as soon as you
instructed me too
we were gonna get hit no matter what
there's nothing you could do to change
that
hey yes
all right we have to make our way to the
space station
over there it's a bit of a hike
we need to use their escape pod the
soyuz to get back to earth
number four star wars the force awakens
thirty years after the defeat of the
galactic empire the galaxy faces a new
threat from the evil kylo ren
in the first order when a defector named
finn crash lands on a desert planet he
meets rey
a tough scavenger whose droid contains a
top secret map
together the young duo joins forces with
han solo to make sure the resistance
receives the intelligence concerning the
whereabouts of luke skywalker
the last of the jedi knights starring
daisy ridley
john boyega adam driver and directed by
jj abrams
critics say packed with action and
populated by both familiar faces and
fresh blood
the force awakens successfully recalls
the series former glory while injecting
it with renewed energy
[Music]
wow
[Music]
try sitting in this thing
[Music]
we need cover quick we're about to get
some
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
[Applause]
come on
number three arrival linguistics
professor louise banks leads an elite
team of investigators when gigantic
spaceships touched down in 12 locations
around the world
as nations teeter on the verge of global
war banks and her crew must race against
time to find a way to communicate with
the extraterrestrial visitors
hoping to unravel the mystery she takes
a chance that could threaten her life
and quite possibly all of mankind
starring amy adams
jeremy renner forest whitaker and
directed by denny velanu
critics say a rival delivers a must-see
experience for fans of thinking person
sci-fi that anchors its heady themes
with genuinely
affecting emotion and a terrific
performance from amy adams
uh so
what happens now
they arrived
so
[Music]
[Music]
number two star wars the last jedi
luke skywalker's peaceful and solitary
existence gets upended when he
encounters rey
a young woman who shows strong signs of
the force her desire to learn the ways
of the jedi forces luke to make a
decision that changes their lives
forever
meanwhile kylo ren and general hux lead
the first order in
an all-out assault against leia and the
resistance for supremacy of the galaxy
starring daisy ridley john boyega adam
driver and directed by ryan johnson
critics say star wars the last jedi
honors the saga's rich legacy while
adding some surprising twists
and delivering all the emotion rich
action fans could hope for
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
and before we reveal number one here are
some honorable mentions
annihilation lina a biologist and former
soldier joins a mission to uncover what
happened to her husband
inside area x a sinister mysterious
phenomenon that is expanding across the
american coastline
once inside the expedition discovers a
world of mutated landscapes
and creatures as dangerous as it is
beautiful that threatens both their
lives and their sanity
starring natalie portman tessa thompson
oscar isaac and directed by alex garland
critics say annihilation backs up its
sci-fi visual wonders and
visceral genre thrills with an
impressively ambitious and
surprisingly strange exploration of
challenging themes that should leave
audiences pondering
long after the end credits roll
ah
don't react
uh
attack the block south london teenagers
defend their neighborhood from evil
extraterrestrials starring john boyega
alex esmal
leon jones and directed by joe cornish
effortlessly mixing scares laughs and
social commentary attack the block is a
thrilling briskly pace sci-fi yarn with
a distinctly british flavor
they found us the hell could they find
us there's like 160 doors in this block
listen whatever kind of gang or [ __ ]
you're involved in leave me out of it
please
hey this ain't got nothing to do with
dance all drugs all rap music or
violence in video games
this is the worst night of my life
feelings
moses ninja tango neutralized
see is that a dog
no that is not a dog
inception dom cobb is a thief with the
rare ability to enter people's dreams
and steal their secrets from their
subconscious
his skill has made him a hot commodity
in the world of corporate espionage but
has also cost him
everything he loves cobb gets a chance
at redemption when he's offered a
seemingly impossible task
plant an idea in someone's mind if he
succeeds it will be the perfect crime
but a dangerous
enemy anticipates cobb's every move
starring leonardo dicaprio
joseph gordon-levitt elliott paige tom
hardy and directed by christopher nolan
critics say smart innovative and
thrilling inception is that rare summer
blockbuster that succeeds viscerally as
well as intellectually
you create the world of the dream we
bring the subject into that dream
and they fill it with their subconscious
how could i ever
acquire enough detail to make them think
that it's reality
well dreams they feel real while we're
in them right
it's only when we wake up that we
realize something was actually strange
let me ask you a question you never
really remember the beginning
of a dream do you always wind up right
in the middle of what's going on
i guess yeah so how did we end up here
well we just came from the uh think
about it ariadne
how did you get here where are you right
now
we're dreaming you're actually in the
middle of the workshop right now
sleeping this is your first lesson in
shared dreaming
[Music]
and finally number one mad max fury road
years after the collapse of civilization
the tyrannical immortan joe enslaves
apocalypse survivors inside the desert
fortress the citadel when the warrior
furiosa leads the
five wives in a daring escape she forges
an alliance with max a loner and former
captive
fortified in the massive armored truck
the war rig
they try to outrun the ruthless warlord
and his henchmen in a deadly high-speed
chase through the wasteland
starring tom hardy charlize theron
nicholas holt and directed by george
miller critics say with exhilarating
action and a surprising amount of
narrative heft
mad max fury road brings george miller's
post-apocalyptic franchise roaring
vigorously back to life
how much more can they take for me i've
got my blood now it's my car
[Music]
you're not just
he looked at me he looked right at me he
looked at your blood back
he turned his head he let me stay in the
eye he was scanning the horizon
no i am awaiting
i have awaited in malala
well friends that about does it for us
be sure to stay tuned to the rotten
tomatoes channel for more of the
entertainment content that you love and
for even more news scores
and recommendations on the latest tv
shows and movies head on over to
rottentomatoes.com
until next time i'm your host naz perez
and we'll see you back here for more top
10s on the rotten tomatoes countdown
[Music]
you